what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
[Music]
in the beginning there was only darkness
an endless expanse of emptiness that
stretched beyond the infinite
and then suddenly
there was everything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
following the incursions of all
realities the universe as we know it
stands as the eighth iteration of its
kind while we don't know much about the
first five what we do know is that the
six the universe was much similar towers
within it resided the x-men the Avengers
the Fantastic Four and a myriad of
familiar entities in the twilight of its
life the six universe gave way to a be
known as the dweller in darkness a demon
hailing from the dimension of ever nigh
the dweller a darkness sustained and
bolstered his powers by feeding on the
fear of living beings seeking to
recreate reality and be born anew as the
multiverse is supreme ruler the dweller
and darkness fracture the m'kraan
crystal which in turn would extinguish
the universe by pulling in the
multiverse and destroying its
inhabitants while the dweller and
darkness was thwarted due to the Phoenix
force uniting the minds of the
universe's inhabitants and peace the end
of reality could not be stopped
but the radiation of the universe's
destruction permeating all existence a
space explorer named Galan of the planet
ah turned to his races knowledge of
Science and Technology and in effort to
both halt the spread of cosmic radiation
as well as prevent the end of all things
failing to find a solution in the final
moments of the multiverse the sixth
universes version of eternity merged
with Galan with the intention of being
born anew and a new multiverse as a
singular being of immense power
following this the cosmic egg of the
seventh multiverse brewed and stirred
amassing energy and gravity until it
reached critical mass and exploded
outward with a big bang
with its primitive universe consisting
of swells of energy the first form of
life to emerge for the cosmic entities
the chief among them being eternity and
infinity serving his twin concepts
eternity represented time and infinity
represented space and while the notions
of both time and space were relative to
the birth and eventual death of the
universe the power of these two beings
hailed from the very fabric of the
universe itself
following this eternity spawned a series
of child entities including empathy
eulogy expediency entropy epiphany
enmity and Aeon all of whom represented
aspects of life in addition to this
eternity and infinity were joined by
Lord chaos and master order representing
the opposing forces of absolute order
and absolute chaos in the universe death
represents in the end of life
oblivion representing the nothingness
between the collapse and rebirth of
universes the Phoenix force representing
the total sum of all psionic energy that
currently has ever and will ever exist
as well as a host of other entities each
representing one or more facets of the
universe where the various entities work
to understand their place in the cosmos
the universe itself continued to unfold
giving way to a multitude of races which
fell and were replaced and turn while
some of these races left behind single
immortal members who came together known
as a group called the elders of the
universe another race was emerging as
the technological superior of the
universe as the most advanced society at
the time the e magmatic race came to
view themselves as a guiding force for
good
christening themselves the watchers and
helping other races to achieve greater
heights through technological
advancement but when one of the races
destroyed themselves with nuclear
weapons the washers retreated from their
role as a guiding force and instead
became chroniclers of the universe as it
unfolded
during this time a race known as the
Celestials began to appear achieving an
extreme level of technology that allowed
the race to move beyond their original
forms taking on a higher level of
existence as peer states of energy
numbering in the billions by the height
of their population the Celestials were
met by an equally powerful foe named the
aspirants who viewed the Celestials as a
challenge to the dominance of all
existence engaging in a war that lasted
centuries where the aspirants decimated
the ranks of the Celestials using the
god-killer armor the Celestials
eventually defeated the aspirants wiping
them from the universe entirely leaving
no sign of their existence for the
exception of records kept and passed
down through generations following this
Galan had remained in hibernation all
the while building a suit designed to
both contain his interviews as well as
regulate those energies to keep from
destroying him emerging several billion
years after the universe's formation
Galan was met with an uncontrollable
hunger for energy found only in planets
capable of supporting life he's setting
his sights on our Kyo Pia which was
immersed in civil war Galan destroyed
the warring fleet Singh consumed the
planet going forward as Galactus the
Devourer of worlds what the universe
continuing to unfold following its
creation and the formation of Galactus
alongside the cosmic entities the
Celestials continued their role as
scientists and explorers planting seeds
inside of planets which in turn would
yield more Celestials the role of
Galactus became a force for containment
as much as it was destruction and that
his consumption of life-sustaining
planets ensured that the Celestials
population remained in check and kept
the race from overtaking the universe
during this time and around 3.5 billion
years ago the earth began to take form
along with the concept of pocket
dimensions
existing within the main Marvel Universe
pocket dimension served as small
sections of reality accessible only
through rifts within the fabric of
space-time
while these dimensions were largely
devoid of life the earth was taking
shape through the process of evolution
giving away to the Elder Gods who were
born to the finest magical energies this
time period also saw the rise of sublime
as a bacterial organism capable of
infecting other organisms around it and
bending them to its will bearing witness
to the evolution of Earth sublime wash
from the shadows as the Elder Gods began
consuming one another and transforming
into demons forcing the goddess Gaea
who represented nature to summon the
Demiurge the sentience of Earth and the
creator of the Elder Gods mating with
Gaia and being born in physical form
Demiurge began to consume all the Elder
Gods with the exception of Siddha rack
the vishanti
Mephisto thermometer and a handful of
others who escaped apakah dimensions
after which Demiurge retreated and
merged with the son
[Music]
I'm doing what I enjoy doing it's like
other men like to play golf so they play
golf every chance they can see you don't
say to him how come you're playing golf
today you played last week was the same
with me to me it is such fun creating
characters writing stories
it's an exciting life and when you do
something that you know the fans seem to
enjoy that gives you such satisfaction
you don't want to stop
[Music]
writing comes very easily to me
everything else in the world is tough
but writing I don't have any problem
with that I can't write fast enough to
keep up with what with the things I want
to say I think you never outgrow your
love of these stories of giants and
ogres and witches and all of that
superhero comics give you that where
most of the pocket dimensions of the
universe began to take shape under the
control of their respective rulers the
dimension of Asgard was coming into
existence according to Norse mythology
asgaard originated as a landmass split
into two sections with the North
existing as a frozen barren wasteland
and the south existing as a fiery barren
wasteland with the two sections having
12 rivers that met in the middle
over time the frozen rivers of the north
began to overtake the south getting way
to the birth of a mirror as the first
frost giant finding himself exposed to
the warmer air of the south the Emir
began to shrink in size
eventually melting away entirely and
revealing a man and a woman following
this above on appear through unknown
means and provided nourishment to the
man and woman through its utters finding
his own sustenance by licking away at
the ice following this pattern the
bovine eventually looked away to block
of ice which revealed itself to be burry
who in turn spawned boar the founder of
Asgard and the father of cruel V Lee V
and Odin where the realm of Asgard would
evolve to see Odin rising to power and
mating with Gaia to produce Thor during
this time a race known as the saurians
traveled the spaceways seeding life
throughout various planets spawning the
Kree the scrolls and humanity who in
turn began to evolve within the confines
of their own planets and forming their
own kingdoms
following this around 1 million years
prior to the current day the Celestials
continue their journey of exploration
across the cosmos
eventually stumbling upon earth viewing
the planet as a host for celestial egg
the Celestials themselves planted their
egg within the earth and began
experimenting on a group of primitive
men known as The Wanderers who were
gathered together by Gaia did the
experiments of the Celestials three
sects were formed the deviants nee
turtles and humans receiving their
modifications from zero on the tester
the deviants represented instability
with their race experiencing unchecked
mutations leading to eats offspring
experiencing a half-life of the previous
generation reducing the overall length
of the deviants expected existence from
nazar the calculator came the Eternals
beings who were perceived to be perfect
in terms of evolutionary maturity and
possess the power to tap into and
manipulate cosmic energies finally Oneg
the prober created a latent gene within
the remaining humans allowing for
limitless expansion of genetic potential
sending the races forward into earth
where the three groups were modified to
serve as protectors of the celestial egg
instead each race gave in to their
natural state the Eternals took to the
skies building kingdoms for themselves
with no concern for the goings-on of
humanity or the deviants at the same
time humanity found itself enslaved by
the deviants who used humans to build
their various structures and cities
lasting until 16,000 BC when the
Celestials appeared on earth a second
time the rachels attacked by the
deviants who view the Celestials as a
threat to the dominion over earth
devastating the deviance numbers and
sending the survivors underground the
Eternals abandon the planet taking up
residence on the Saturn moon Titan as
well as exploring the rest of the cosmos
leaving a landscape of Earth open
humanity began to spread and expand
their sphere of influence to the
furthest corners of the world creating
empires and kingdoms
with each worshipping their own deities
during this time and while in the midst
of a war with their rival race the
scrolls the Kree race observe the
actions of the Celestials and look to
expand their own sphere of influence by
modifying the genes of humanity allowing
them to take on forms identical to other
races which in turn would allow the Kree
to subvert those races from within
paving the way for them to conquer those
planets kidnapping various humans and
modifying their genes
the Kree ruler known as the supreme
intelligence foresaw the end of their
race at the hands of their experiments
and in turn
ordered all experiments to be cleansed
and all knowledge or existence to be
stripped from Kree records however in
its rush to judgment the supreme
intelligence failed to take notice of
five experiments in the form of
primitive man
the Badoon the dire race the chameleons
and the Centurions where each of these
groups continued on unaware of their
lineage within the confines of Earth the
Kree experiments began to form their own
order society under the theme of a
monarchy to descend in at some point in
their past a geneticist named Rand AK
discovered Terrigen crystals and began
to synthesize the process of
terrigenesis allowing the human
experiments to under no exposure to the
myths which in turn transmogrified the
humans and unrecognizable forms but
sometimes possessing extraordinary
abilities christening themselves in
humans the race kept itself isolated
within the sacred city of Attilan and
away from the goings-on of the deviants
and the rest of humanity where the
Inhumans remain isolated because of the
actions of the Celestials and pushing
the deviance to near extinction
technology was lost to humanity for
millennia sending the race into a near
feral state referred to as a Hyborian
age this time period not only saw the
introduction of Conan the Barbarian in
red Sonia but also saw the rise of the
first mutant as well as direct
interaction with the second generation
of gods while almost nothing is known of
Celine's past what we do know is that
because Selene maintains her longevity
by absorbing life energies through
physical touch during the time of her
birth she unintentionally killed her
mother
viewing Salinas a goddess destined to
rule the world the tribal leaders of the
clan ordered Celine's people to
sacrifice their lives so they may live
forever as part of her where Selene
would spend the next several thousand
years wandering the world her journeys
allowed her to witness the rise of the
second generation of gods coming in the
form of Norse Greek Roman and other
cultural mythologies while these gods
had existed for countless years this
time period saw their first interactions
with society at large because of this
the cultures of the world gave way to
warship to Odin Zeus Vishnu Yahweh and
Amun rah
among others while this remained the
standard practice of humanity's
relationship with the second generation
of gods the world was met with the
arrival of its second unit and 5000 BC
but I enjoy the people I work with
because I work with writers with artists
now with directors producers and I'm
always working in an atmosphere where
we're trying to think of what can we do
now
the small blue sphere existed as one of
countless worlds within countless
universes developing their own lives and
civilizations all of which had been set
in motion by the one above all and
watched closely by the Living Tribunal
known as the multiverse beyond this
space existed what was known only as the
beyond verse housing the white Lords of
wild space while their origin is unknown
unlike the multiverse the beyond verse
did not allow for travel between the
past and the present instead the
inhabitants of the beyond verse move
forward from one point in time to the
next towards a future that could not be
changed all the while developing
technologies and a level of power
hitherto unrivaled traveling back to our
universe and within the Andromeda galaxy
rested the planets Chronos in the Drakh
system in its early days approximately
100 million years ago after their
creation by the saurians the scrolls
existed as a reptilian race not unlike
the smaller reptiles of Earth however
after their exposure to the Celestials
during their journey of exploration with
scientific experimentation much like
humanity the scroll race was split into
three sects the deviants the Eternals
and the baseline scrolls with modified
genes allowing for future mutations
while much of the races of history is
lost to the sands of time what we do
know is that at some point in their past
unlike the human Eternals who left earth
to explore the Stars the civil war
between the eternal and deviant Scrolls
saw the deviants victorious pushing the
eternal Scrolls to the brink of
extinction what the eternal scrolls all
the dead the last of this group Avena
and kleben convinced the deviant queen
sluggard to spare his life and take his
hand in marriage offering up a truce in
the process leaving a scroll race in
true a religion known as the book of
worlds all surviving factions of the
scrolls were united under this ideology
and moved forward and a manner akin to
manifest destiny believing it was their
role to rule over the universe
following this and for countless eons
the scrolls expanded their reach across
the andromeda galaxy but as their
exposure to and subsequent conquering of
other races swell their number many
Scrolls became disillusioned with the
book of worlds slipping into the realm
of myth and legend the scroll Empire
went to war with itself each time
emerging more technologically advanced
and benign by weeding out those who
sought to bring disharmony to this end
and after having transformed into a
society of space explorers on a mission
of peace the scrolls traveled to the
planet Hollow within the greater
Magellanic Cloud discovering the planet
house two equally intelligent races
known as the Kree in the catotti for the
Scrolls considering halle is a possible
expansion of their empire a group of
Korean cotati were taken aboard a scroll
vessel and transported to the
oxygen-rich blue area of Earth's moon
provided with the years where the
supplies and destructed by the scroll
delegation to build something worthy of
their own race while the coach Hadi used
their plant like design to build a lush
jungle comprised of flora and fauna the
Kree built a massive city accessible
only to themselves and the scrolls
viewing the core toddies benign work is
worthy of its initiation into the Empire
and a fit of jealousy the Kree killed
the Cotati and the scroll delegation
looting their ship and assimilating
their technology traveling back to their
homeworld the Kree waged war against the
remainder of the Cotati race pushing
them to the brink of extinction while
taking the planet of holo as the relman
following this and with knowledge of the
Kree assault when the scroll delegation
reaching the Kree homeworld the two
races fell into war with one another
which would stretch over hundreds of
millennia using their own forms of
science and technology to engineer
weapons of destruction the Skrulls
turned their sights to opening
dimensional rifts for the purpose of
accessing forms of energy
guaranteed to annihilate their enemies
accessing the beyond verse through sheer
accident the scrolls secured a fraction
of the beyonders power which confined
itself to the shape of a perfect cube
seizing it for himself in using its
power to control matter in energy the
scroll Emperor fancied himself a God
ruling without challenge unbeknownst to
the emperor the cube develops sentience
copying the maniacal tendencies of the
emperor and annihilating two-thirds of
the andromeda galaxy while the scrolls
would rebuild their empire and consider
the Cosmic Cube to be an artifact too
dangerous to possess after witnessing
its power the Kree race came to the
realization that they would need a
guiding force without the limitations of
natural drive or possible betrayal and
so under the guidance of the Kree
Science Council the race formed a
sentient computer known as the supreme
intelligence containing the minds of
every career or the supreme intelligence
became as much as spiritual symbol as it
was a leader guiding the Kree with her
absolute loyalty the supreme
intelligence orchestrated the
development of the inhuman project as a
means to both subvert the SPRO race as
well as other races in an effort to
secure the kree's dominion over the
universe
however at some point in the races
history an unnamed member had attempted
to secure an artifact known as the
crystal of ultimate vision which allowed
its wielder to perceive and manipulate
the very fabric of the universe giving
in to his basic instincts the unknown
Kriya the final test which measure the
potential wielder spirit as a result the
evolution of the Cree race was frozen in
time keeping them in their current form
until the end of all things
on the other side of the cosmos the
Shiar were developing their own empire
originating with Shara and key 3
according to Shiar legend the two
possessed untold power but existed as
opposites through good and evil waging
war against one another forced to marry
through unknown means Shara and kii
three were presented with the m'kraan
crystal which had reformed through the
birth of this new universe representing
the union of Shara and ki 3 the m'kraan
crystal came to be viewed as a sacred
artifact to this end the Shiar turned to
the crystal as a representation of their
races destiny to marry planets together
under the monarchy of the Shiar Empire
taking place over the course of yawns
and expanding across their corner of the
galaxy
unlike the scroll Empire which
functioned with the scrolls themselves
at the center of power the Shiar Empire
existed as an amalgamation of races with
each one swearing absolute allegiance to
the imperial crown shortly after this
and in an effort to secure their safety
over their rule the Shiar developed the
Imperial Guard offering all members of
the Empire and opportunity to
participate each race was allowed to
send one member of their kind who stood
as the races strongest individual as a
result the Imperial Guard was only
comprised of a small number of members
but each one possessed a unique power
ranging from telepathy to telekinesis to
energy manipulation
while the Shiar Empire continued to grow
and expand within its own corner of the
universe the Eternals who would abandon
earth had already taken up residence on
Saturn's moon Titan winding the clock
back prior to the Eternals abandoning
earth the group found itself led by two
beings Chronos who sought peace and
Uranus who sought war with the
inevitable Civil War coming to fruition
Uranus and his ilk were exiled from
Earth eventually taking up residence on
Titan however because the Eternals were
at their core humans one of the elder
gods known as a dragon of the moon
reached out from its dimension and
looked to enhance his power by
corrupting the Wills of madmen and sorry
Uranus and his followers into a civil
war the entirety of the colony was
nearly destroyed save for sweets on an
eternal woman who remained alone on the
desolate moon following this and after
the remainder of Earth's Eternals took
to the stars
sui-lan was greeted by those who stayed
behind and took up residence on titan as
a means to continue monitoring earth
finding herself married to a lars around
20,000 years prior to the current day
Lars and sweets on gave birth to two
sons named eros and panels developing a
highly advanced computer system named
Isaac and repopulate and tightening
while a large and sweet Sean found
themselves elevated to the position of
rulers over the moon unbeknownst to the
rest of the universe a small corner of
reality took a different direction
within the Cygnus constellation and
residing is a fourth planet from its Sun
then lost it as a beacon of scientific
and technological superiority while his
origin is shrouded in mystery we can
largely assume that in the early days of
its development zenn-la experienced its
own struggles as the planets inhabitants
came to understand their place in the
universe along the way the zenn-la vien
belief indeed he's began to fade
following the rise of throng the saint
of science teaching the people of
zenn-la to concern themselves with only
what could be witnessed and analyzed by
their eyes the actions of thron assured
a scientific age of enlightenment at the
cost of creating a rift between himself
as well as his fellow gods and his son
la viens owing to the idea that belief
in mythical beings defy the nature of
science itself
using their knowledge of science and a
defensive capacity zenn-la saw the
issues of hunger disease and poverty
swept away to be replaced by a paradise
where each member lived without want
however this enlightenment came with a
high price as a race that had previously
experienced hatred and war the citizens
of zenn-la were not unlike humans and
that they thrived on freewill and
imagination while the early days of
their scientific discovery allow for
exploration of the Stars after charting
all things and learning all there was to
learn the act of retreating into
themselves left a void in their nature
with some turning to drugs and others
turning to suicide to escape into a
mental dreamscape while their society
did not crumble it slowly reduced itself
in number all the while becoming removed
from the goings-on of the universe
around the remaining secluded from all
existence in our stories I would
occasionally have somebody die or
introduce a serious subject I didn't
like to do it too much because basically
I feel comic books for anything I do
whether it's comic books or movies or
television or animation should be
entertaining and I never want to and
most of what I do is for younger people
I consider people in their 20s younger
in fact right now I consider people in
their 70s younger but at any rate it was
for younger people and I didn't feel
they should be burdened with too much
heavy stuff I thought they should read
my stories enjoy them and come away
feeling better but at the same time and
trying to inject some reality some
realism into the stories and also to
surprise the readers because it's
important for a reader never to know
what's coming next but occasionally I
should have somebody die or get
seriously ill occasionally touch on some
serious subject now those are two
separate things the having somebody die
was for the sake of drama and holding
the readers interest
the age of empires progressed all forms
of life ranging from these spacefaring
forces to single-celled organisms all
existed as but one version of themselves
within our universe beyond this resented
the multiverse
a mass of interweaving of realities
while some of these universes were
identical to our own others differed
greatly if the legends of old are to be
believed at the beginning of all things
before the formation of the first
universe there existed that one above
all as the supreme creator as well as
nemesis possessing control over
space-time the sole reality the mind and
pure power as the sole entity existence
nemesis fell into a state of loneliness
and despair electing to end its own life
dispersing its energies and their
entirety
nemesis gave birth to the multiverse
planting within each universe six
singular gems containing a portion of
its power travelling back to our
universe as the empires of various races
grew and were replaced the universe was
being explored by the Phoenix force
unlike the traditional cosmic entities
of eternity infinity Galactus and others
the Phoenix force did not contain
different iterations of itself across
the multiverse instead despite the
existence of infinite universes within
the multiverse there existed only one
Phoenix force representing the total sum
of all future life born through the
multiverse itself the Phoenix force
existed with immense power serving as a
nexus for all psychic energy that has
ever currently does or will ever exist
initially existing as a formless mass of
energy while we don't know what the
Phoenix was doing in the early days of
the universe what we do know is that in
a universe wildly different from our own
a being named net crumb had come to
understand the power of the Phoenix
operating is that universes sorcerer
supreme
nekron had taken advantage of the
Phoenix forces lack of experience in
dealing with deception manipulating the
Phoenix into building pillars across the
multiverse net Crom intended to converge
all realities into a singularity forcing
a collapse of the multiverse and
absorbing the energy submitted by its
death
transforming him into a God however the
schemes of nekron were discovered by his
students and while he was defeated the
Phoenix went forward operating largely
within our universe and seeking to
better understand the minds of mortal
creatures with the threat of neck kromm
reaching the ears of almost all beings
across the multiverse an individual of
unknown origin named Merlin had come to
the conclusion that the various
realities of the multiverse needed a
means of observation and protection
against such a threat confining himself
to a pocket dimension outside of all
space and time known as Otherworld
Merlin said about creating the
omniversal Development Court a governing
body designed to observe the development
of each universe within the multiverse
and ensure their safety
traveling back towel universe while the
planet zenn-la
remained in isolation from the various
empires and forms of life their position
in the cosmos was about to radically
change on the far side of reality
Galactus continued his role as the
devourer of worlds and found that his
hunger was growing traversing the cosmos
and coming upon zenn-la as one of the
many worlds rich in life supporting
energy Galactus intended to consumes in
law however had to be Hess of one of its
citizenry his in-laws execution was
stay'd born to the brilliant scientist
Geron who encouraged his son to pursue
knowledge advancement and achievement
unlike everybody else sons in law who
saw Galactus coming as their guaranteed
end
Norrin Radd saw hope petitioning zen law
Science Council to grant him a vessel
Norrin Radd struck a pact with Galactus
with the devourer of worlds becoming
increasingly weaker due to having to
search at his own sustenance
if Galactus peers in law no one rat
would abandon his home and service
Galactus is Herald traveling the
universe in search of suitable planets
agreeing to these terms
Norrin Radd was transformed into the
Silver Surfer who in turn would locate
planets capable of say shading the
likenesses hunger but lacking sentient
life but the Silver Surfer serving his
purpose back in our solar system the
destiny of Thanos was beginning as the
son of the Lars an eternal from Earth
Thanos was at his core human but with
both Eternals and deviance stemming from
the human gene unlike those around him
on Titan Thanos was born with both
eternal and deviant genes making him a
mutant among his own race however unlike
a Lars who considered a no so worthy
successor to the eternal throne Thanos
his mother cerise on saw him as the
death of them all
initially trying to kill her son on
birth while sweets on was stopped by at
Lars her claims of impending doom at the
hands of panis led to her incarceration
within a mental institution
spinning his childhood as a pacifist
Thanos kept largely to himself playing
only with his brother eros however after
encountering a fellow student her
manipulations began to see the views of
Thanos shifting from non-aggression to
obsession with nihilism and death
encouraged by his family to develop
friends the young Thanos was tricked
into visiting a cave alongside several
other students experiencing a cave-in
Thanos was forced to be a witness as his
friends were consumed by lizards forced
to return to a life of isolation the
young girl persuaded Thanos to drop his
pacifist nature returning to the cave
and killing the lizards following this
and at the behest of the young girl
Thanos began kidnapping various
creatures from around his city
initiating a series of grisly
experiments that kill them but enable
Thanos to better understand the natural
physiology of organisms and his search
to understand why he was physically
different from everyone else continuing
along this path by his teenage years and
after expanding his experiments to his
own race Thanos had murdered 17
individuals many of whom were his own
classmates failing to find his answers
the more Thanos engaged in murder the
more his focus shifted from research to
desire after which he abandoned Titan
and took to exploring the stars while
the path of Thanos would lead him
inexorably towards his fate back on
earth the Elder Gods refused to be
forgotten after spending 3 billion years
in isolation a handful of elder gods
sought to use mankind as a means to
ensure their legacy coming together in
the form of the octet since the Elder
Gods were tuned Bhavik Econ for allah
sidorak kraken ragged org and vault r
came together for a test to determine
the strongest member among them creating
an artifact of their own design those
humans who continued to worship the
Elder Gods built tombs housing these
artifacts sealing the tombs and
sacrificing their lives these items
would remain until one was touched by
human hands after which humanity would
be drawn to the remaining seven than
those that acquired them would lead
humanity and a war against itself while
time would see the passing of 4000 years
before this prophecy would be fulfilled
with the existence of these artifacts
remaining hidden the ancient mutant
apocalypse was beginning his reign
following his escape from the confines
of Egypt of Hakka lafe's went forward
throughout the world pitting various
civilizations against one another as a
means to eliminate the weak from the
strong during this time and in the
fifteenth century in sub on or had
fancied himself a warlord building an
army of the strongest fighters from
those civilizations he had conquered and
christening them the riders of the dark
using the riders to conquer more
territories the life events of on or in
the future of the world was changed
irrevocably with the arrival of Nathan
Dayspring hailing from 4,500 years in
the future cable from the time of his
adolescence knew only of a world ruled
by apocalypse imposing his philosophy of
social Darwinism under the rule of
apocalypse Murphy had become a cruel and
brutal place for the weak were
eliminated to make way for the strong
intending to keep his future from coming
into fruition cable travelled into the
past under the guise of the traveler
intending to end apocalypse before he
could seize power however during in sub
onerous travels he had encountered a
ship left behind by the Celestials
during their experiments on early man
unable to access its technology during
his original encounter apocalypse
greeted cable as an enemy with the two
doing battle against one another while
cable proved himself the victor his
sovereign ended blood merged with
apocalypse allowing him to communicate
with the ship
striking a patch with one of the
Celestials apocalypse was granted use of
their technology and went forward with a
host of new powers hell-bent on world
domination very witness to the fruits of
his labor Kaiba was forced to come to
recognize that he himself was the being
responsible for engineering apocalypses
rise to power
the most important thing that I always
tried to do was concentrate on the
characters even before I would dream up
the story I would try to think who are
the characters what are their
personalities what type of people are
they and why should a reader care about
them why should a real reader be
interested in them to me the same thing
holds for movies television you've got
to have characters that the audience the
viewer the reader cares about once you
do that making up stories is easy the
serious themes that I would occasionally
inject were for another reason I began
to realize judging by the fan mail that
we received I began to realize that our
books had quite an influence on the
readers and I kind of took that
seriously I felt if these people are
reading my words and the words of the
other writers working for horrible
I felt we've got to be careful and we've
got to make sure that we're not giving
them the wrong messages while apocalypse
is packed with the Celestials allowed
him to go forward from Egypt as the most
powerful earthbound being at the time
and forcing civilizations around the
world to worship him as a God on the
other side of the Nile River and North
East Africa gods of a different sort
were becoming involved in the affairs of
humanity wanting the clock back to three
billion years ago
following the banishment of the Elder
Gods Gaia who embodied the Earth Spirit
spawned children of her own
who took three forms the Titans the
Cyclops and the hectars favored by their
father
arrey knows the Titans embodied his lust
for battle in his formidable strength
testing one another through physical
combat the Titans ruled from on high as
their brothers the Cyclops and hectares
were banished to the other dimensional
realm of Tartarus grieving for her
children
Gaia besieged the Titans to destroy
Raynaud's a task ignored by all than one
seeing the opportunity as a chance to
rule and taking up arms against his
father
the youngest Titan named Cronus
castrated him murdered array knows who
used his dying breath to curse Cronus
with death by his own son refusing to
honor the request of his mother to free
his brothers and seizing Mount Olympus
as his own
Cronus took a bride in the form of Rhea
who in turn gave birth to Zeus turning
against her son Gaia smuggle disease
from Olympus raising him to become a
fierce warrior growing into adulthood
Zeus freed the Cyclops and hectars
leading a march against Cronus and his
Titans defeating his father all the
Titans soldiers were banished to the
realm of Tartarus where they were
watched over by Hades allowing Zeus to
emerge as the king of gods turning his
sights to the Titan General Atlas Zeus
dispersed Eagles across the earth
surveying his domain and locating the
center of the world Atlas was imprisoned
on the island of Atlantis doomed to
spend eternity holding the heavens on
his shoulders becoming a home for the
deviants following the first experiments
of the Celestials the kingdom of
Atlantis served as a trading hub of the
deviants themselves and free men
allowing sailors and merchants to barter
trinkets and items from around the world
spanning the globe in reaching as far
south as Antarctica the Atlantean
civilization discovered the Savage Land
as a place of beauty housing flora and
fauna exporting animals from around the
globe
despite their advanced technology and
attempts at explaining how such a lush
jungle could exist in the Antarctic the
truth of the Savage Land eluded the
Atlanteans however during the deviants
battle with the Celestials the highly
advanced Atlantean civilization immersed
itself in spheres of unknown composition
under the belief that the conflict would
lay waste to the world bearing witness
as the deviant and celestial war shook
the skies and threatened to crack the
earth into the island of Atlantis fell
beneath the surface where he would
remain hidden from those on land
as the ages passed and time allowed for
mankind to flourish on the surface
primitive tendencies gave way to a
reconstruction of organized society
constructing empires that grew through
conquests and were conquered and turned
the kingdom of Atlantis evolved as well
with all technology lost to save for
their protective spheres and
miscellaneous instruments using their
knowledge of alchemy Atlantean priests
began to modify the genetic structure of
their people allowing for the ability to
breathe underwater remaining isolated
from the goings on in the surface this
time period of Atlantean history saw the
rise of two of history's most important
beings Meriden and Morgan la Fey
departing the kingdom of Atlantis and
taking up residence in Great Britain
where Morgan la Fey opposed the idea of
Britain transforming into a religious
Empire Meriden supported the cause
forming a pact with Mordred the
illegitimate son of King Arthur Morgan
LaFace saw to subvert Arthur's rule over
Britain capturing the kingdom of Camelot
and eventually the world invoking his
knowledge of alchemy Muradin rechristen
himself Merlin and using his magic to
empower the ebony sword selected Sir
Percy of scandia to protect the kingdom
of Camelot operating as an agent of both
Merlin and King Arthur Sir Percy of
scandia defended Camelot on several
occasions saving the life of King Arthur
and securing his legacy as one of
Camelot's greatest warriors however
unbeknownst to King Arthur Merlin or Sir
Percy himself the ebony blade had a will
of its own forged through combat and
solidified through bloodshed the ebony
blade developed a curse dooming all who
wielded the sword to a hunger for battle
meeting his death during the fall of
Camelot the spirit of Sir Percy endured
appearing to all descendants of his
bloodline who were found worthy of
wielding the sword
moving away from britain within the
territories of both Africa and Egypt a
handful of second-generation gods had
formed their own followings originating
in Egypt proper unlike her counterparts
who maintained their ties to the
Egyptian culture the Panther God bast
elected to forge ties to both Egypt and
Africa worship within the Egyptian city
of Bubastis as they got us a pleasure
the adoption of bast as an African
goddess did not occur until 10,000 years
ago hailing from the far side of the
universe whether through fate or divine
means a meteorite smashed into the
atmosphere scattering debris across the
planet while some landed in Antarctica
itself and various other territories
around the globe the largest fragment
made landfall in Wakanda discovered by
bashing de who led a small band of
nomads the vibranium meteorite was
believed to be a gift from Africa's gods
forging weapons that utilize vibranium
natural ability to absorb sound and
energy where one half of the dschinghis
tribe went forward as a dominant group
in Africa the other half were mutated to
the radiation permeated by the vibranium
or becoming demons of darkness and rage
praying to the African goddess bast to
aid his people the shingu was bestowed
with the powers of the Panther God
defeating the dark demons serving as
protector of wakanda's vibranium stores
which she got kept his lands hidden from
the world
all the while continuing to utilize the
powers of the black panther and becoming
the first in a line of descendants who
would share this role
while the small settlement of Wakanda
began its journey to become a kingdom
the various members of the second
generation of gods were becoming more
involved in the lives of mortal men
forming a Council of godheads known of
the sky fathers within the territories
of Greece India Scandinavia and North
America these sky fathers represent to
the various religions of the world
ranging from Christianity and
Catholicism to Hinduism and Taoism
routinely interacting with humanity
albeit by indirect means not all who
were aware of this influence approved
returning to earth for a third time with
the intention of judging humanity's
evolution is worthy of continued
existence the Celestials were displeased
with the sky father's influence on human
civilization bringing with them the
power to destroy the sky fathers with
but a thought the Council of godheads
were instructed to refrain from
involving themselves in the affairs of
mortal men blessed they fund their
empires destroyed and their lives
forfeit as a result the sky fathers
grudgingly honored this request where
their legacies fading from humanity's
mind to be replaced by myths and legend
by the 12th century humanity sat nestled
in the Middle Ages or this era would see
the rise of Genghis Khan who would go on
to form the largest empire recorded
history at the time as well as the
tail-end of the religious Crusades one
of the most powerful mutants to have
ever existed was running headlong into
his destiny born to a wealthy French
family Bennet dupe Howie had wanted for
virtually nothing fighting in the
crusade as an adult during his travels
the pole of Destiny had revealed
whispers of an eternal Pharaoh in Egypt
capable of granting untold power driven
by ambition Bennet travelled to Egypt
after which he was met with a
disembodied voice asking if Bennet was
willing to sacrifice who he was to
become something better his powers were
awakened granting him a level of
telepathy and telekinesis hitherto
unchallenged forced to do battle as the
test of his abilities Bennet dupe Harry
emerged victorious going forward as
Exodus however unbeknownst to Exodus his
powers had been awakened by apocalypse
forced to do battle against his allies
Exodus turned on apocalypse proclaiming
him a false god
engaging in a battle against the tyrant
alongside his allies exodus was swiftly
overpowered after which he was sealed
away within a mountainside
while Exodus slumbered within a script
300 years past and saw the world
changing Europe was experiencing a
renaissance of art and science the Roman
Empire was collapsing and Joan of Arc
was turning the tide of the Hundred
Years War between England and France
during this time and within the mystic
city of Qom our Taj in the region of
Tibet on the western side of the
Himalayas the world was met with the
birth of Yama spending his youth as a
peaceful farmer yah was greeted by a
fellow villager named Kowloon exposing
now to knowledge of magic and sorcery
the two journey together through the
realm of mystic arts learning to control
the wills of men and harnessing the
power of immortality
however as Kalu expand his knowledge of
sorcery so too did he expand his lust
for power taking over the minds of local
farmers the maniacal tendencies of
colluded led to a battle between himself
and yow laying waste to the city of Qom
art Amish yah banish collude to the
crimson dimension of city rock after
which the out christened himself the
ancient and sought others like himself
[Music]
it really has to do with talent I think
the people at marble or making these
movies are the most talented movie
makers on the face of the planet they go
back to the roots of the comics and they
say what made this trip so successful
and once they decide what that element
or those elements may be they keep to
those elements they're starting out with
very colorful characters but if they put
them in the real world and they give
them real problems and everybody wants
to see it I I know the characters and I
can't wait to see the movies
[Music]
and if you see for me superheroes will
always spark the imagination of people
around the world regardless of their
background because I think that people
are always looking for something that
represents the ideal person or the ideal
situation one thing I might mention most
writers and I think it's an unfortunate
thing they try to write something that
they think a certain audience might
enjoy I've never been able to do that
because I can't put myself in the mind
of other people I only know what I enjoy
so every time I've written a story I've
always tried to write the sort of story
that I myself would enjoy reading a
story that would interest me
while I'm writing it as I'm waiting to
find out what happens next as the
journey of the ancient one continued
leaving him ever closer to his encounter
with dr. Stephen strange one of the
world's most dangerous villains was
emerging while almost nothing is known
about his parents or birthplace what is
known is that as a child Nathaniel Essex
was gifted with an aptitude for
intelligence which largely went
unexplored until his adolescence
journeying to Greenwich Park in London
Essex did not view the world like
everyone else were the citizens of
London looked to religion as an answer
to their purpose in life
Essex believed that the gods were but
one facet of the universe with humanity
moving forward toward his guaranteed
future applying his intelligence as a
means to understand the place of
humanity within the cosmos Essex
received a full scholarship to Oxford
University where he pursued a career in
biology
becoming obsessed with evolution Essex
came to believe that humanity stood upon
the precipice of change and that if it
had not begun already our time would
come when human beings will begin to
evolve creating a crude representation
of what these future humans may look
like Nathaniel Essex was denounced and
exiled from the Royal Academy of
Sciences all the while remaining
completely unaware that he was being
watched by curious eyes despite having
lived for thousands of years in
traveling to virtually every corner of
the world Apocalypse had remained
woefully oblivious to his true heritage
disguising himself as a benefactor and
travelling to London through the
conversations and investigations
apocalypse came to realize that his
powers did not hail from divine
intervention but through a mutation in
his genes offering Nathaniel the
opportunity to continue his
experimentation without the restriction
of age
apocalypse use his celestial technology
to modify the genes of Essex allowing
him to go forward as mr. sinister
or the journeys of Essex would see him
continuing his experiments on the other
side of the Atlantic Ocean
another mutant was emerging nestled
within Alberta Canada's lakeland
district in 1885 James Howlett was born
to Elizabeth Hallett and the family's
ground keeper Thomas Logan ignored by
his mother and shunned by his father
James spent the early days of his youth
under the abuse of control of his
grandfather who routinely beat his
grandson believing that a firm and harsh
a brain was necessary its submitting his
time with two other children named rose
and dog the biological son of Thomas
Logan and half-brother to James as the
three grew into adulthood their
attention began to shift to romance
finding himself attracted to Rose
because dog had experienced such brutal
punishment at the hands of his father
like a feral animal Dodd forced himself
onto rose leading to the expulsion of
both dog and his father from the
hallowed estate flying into a drunken
rage Thomas returned to the estate
murdering James father in front of him
overtaken by grief and rage the powers
of James manifested resulting in the
protrusion of bone claws and a healing
factor after which James killed Thomas
and left his home alongside rose
moving away from Earth and transitioning
to a frontier world in the Crab Nebula
Thanos continued his journey living an
empty and unfulfilled life Thanos
produced children looted the worlds of
Fringe galaxies and murdered failing to
fill the void of his life the more
children he produced the more people he
killed and the more worlds he pillaged
the lessee felt instead and despite his
best efforts his thoughts wandered
across the vastness of space to the
young girl on Titan who guided him
towards his first steps in killing
curious as to her whereabouts
Thanos his attempt to drive her from his
mind saw him taking up work on the [ __ ]
coast a pirate vessel led by a demented
captain challenging the captain for
leadership of the Pirates Thanos his
victory saw him giving in to his
bloodlust going forward as the mad Titan
however would the mysterious young girl
tormenting his every waking thought and
every sleeping dream Thanos
took his pirates and returned home in an
effort to find her
back on earth the 1793 advent of the
cotton gin had marked the midway point
of the Industrial Revolution and where
technology was advancing to allow for a
better understanding of the world
unbeknownst to all the entity sublime
watched closely evolving with the first
forms of life on Earth
sublime had spent countless eons jumping
from one house to the next using each
human to carry out its schemes and
sowing chaos and reaping Wars however
with the emergence of mutants the
alteration to their genetic code made
them immune to the influence of sublime
as such the entity began laying plans
for weapons plus a program rooted in the
idea of creating super soldiers during
this time the kingdom of austria-hungary
remained the weakest of the first world
nations a situation exacerbated by the
desire of the South Slavic people to
break away and form their own nation of
Yugoslavia where most look to diplomacy
as a means to achieve their goal
a group of Serbian nationalists calling
themselves a black hand chose another
path intending to eliminate Franz
Ferdinand the nephew of austria-hungary
Emperor Franz Josef the black hands
belief was that in doing so friends
Joseph would acquiesce and allow this
house Slavs to break away carrying their
mission to its completion instead of
allowing the South Slavs to form their
own nation and for Franz Josef waged war
international alliances were invoked and
World War one began as the powers of the
world squabbled over land and glory
Sablan continued to operate in the
shadows using the post-world War One
chaos of Central Europe to his advantage
sublime took over the body of a human
host dubbing himself John and began to
manipulate various intelligence agencies
around the United States
arguing that the threat of world war one
proposed a legitimate need for
super-powered beings who would fight on
behalf of the United States sublime was
given a blank cheque by the US
government using those funds to bring
his vision into reality the coinciding
with Hitler's invasion of Poland and the
start of World War two word had reached
the ears of Sivan regarding a German
scientist who had successfully developed
a serum that augmented the abilities of
normal men working alongside the United
States military
John sublime orchestrated the kidnapping
of dr. Abraham Erskine by Nick Fury and
his Howling Commandos after which
Erskine was sent a task and locating the
best suitable candidate for the use of
his formula spending several years
sorting through various soldiers Abraham
Erskine finally settled on a young
emaciated man whose lack of size
hindered his attempts to enter the US
Army electing to meet the boy in person
dr. Erskine was impressed by the man's
courage and bravery leading to the
development of the web and Plus projects
for a successful test subject in the
form of Captain America origins of
superpowers are always very interesting
if you get the right origin like for
example spider-man being bitten by a
radioactive spider at least then the
viewer has something to hold on to and
to say well it might have happened
now I'll enjoy it
I can tell you exactly when timely
comics became Marvel the last name they
had before they became Marvel was Atlas
comics and after we did the Fantastic
Four we did the Hulk spider-man the
x-men so forth we suddenly began to
realize hey we've got fans so I decided
we ought to change the name of the
company get something better than Atlas
and the very first book that martin
goodman had ever published was called
marvel comics
winding the clock back to the late
eleven hundreds while the rest of the
world saw the rise of Empires who
squabbled over land and power not every
organization chose to operate in the
light within the nation of Japan
Minamoto no your moto had founded the
first of the Shogun in 1192 ruling over
japan as a military dictator the
official class of its society followed a
hierarchy beginning with its line of
Kings extending to feudal lords with
peasants and artisans at the bottom and
to me to escape this class of inequality
a handful of peasants and artisans took
to the mountains of EAGA and Koga
living isolated from the larger society
these small bands practiced the art of
ninjitsu passing their teachings on to
their children maintaining this
lifestyle in 1588 these isolated tribes
were bound together under the rule of
kaga Nobu Yoshioka rechristening this
organization as the hand they maintained
their clandestine nature coveting power
above all else and influencing the
governments of the world through
subterfuge and assassinations by the
early 20th century the world had changed
global exploration and the founding of
new territories gave way to
international alliances through trade
and commerce
while individual rulers came and went on
the whole the borders had already been
drawn within Europe in the Middle East
the post-world War one landscape saw the
actions of Leon Trotsky and Vladimir
Lenin paving the way for the reformation
of Russia from an imperialist nation to
the Communist USSR the Serbians
Croatians and Slovenians form Yugoslavia
Czechoslovakia Bohemia and Hungary
formed their own territory and the
Ottoman Empire was replaced by the
formation of Turkey along with a handful
of other Federation's in the West the
United States in Britain became
superpowers referred to as the roaring
20s for the American people
consumer spending was at an all-time
high owing to the decreased cost of
goods through supply-side economics
the motion picture industry was emerging
in Hollywood California and mass
production had transitioned automobiles
from a luxury to a commonly owned
product of the middle-class conversely
the early 1920s saw massive social
changes for women in Brittany with World
War one seemed so many men fighting
overseas women turned to working in
factories providing a wage and a measure
of Independence and the post-world War
one landscape however this autonomy
remained seeing the introduction of
voting rights in 1918 to women over the
age of 30 and an extension to these
rights to women over the age of 21 by
1928 these changes and others elevated
women from their previous positions as
being subservient to cutting their hair
wearing shorter dresses and taking on
the moniker a flapper for the German
people however economic and social
growth was nowhere to be found
viewed as the agitators of World War one
owing to the idea that they had merged
austria-hungary Emperor Franz Joseph and
the waging war against Serbia following
his nephews assassination Germany was
considered to be the prime target for
the Paris Peace Conference and the
Treaty of Versailles and forced by the
newly formed League of Nations which was
composed of World War Ones victors to
ensure a Second World War did not happen
the Treaty of Versailles required that
Germany give up all territories obtained
during the second reich of otto von
bismarck losing access to 16 percent of
its coal fields and half of its iron and
steel industry the additional impacts of
armed forces reductions and reparations
virtually shattered the German economy
sending it into a tailspin of
destitution and resentment forced to
bear witnesses land was purchased by
foreigners who in turn started
businesses and built homes a small facet
of German nationalists espoused the
belief that their national identity was
slowly being eroded going relatively
unnoticed except for those who attended
their meetings and small facilities on
the outskirts and due time the
Nationalist Party found a voice who
rallied their cause and would take
Germany by storm
by 1929 the American stock market
crashed during what's become known as
Black Thursday with reliance on the
League of Nations super powers to
enforce mandates and the reluctance of
the United States to financially back
restrictions when they were facing the
Great Depression the world was gearing
up for the unavoidable in Italy Benito
Mussolini marched on Rome in 1922 and
wrestled control from King Victor
Emmanuel the third taking over his prime
minister and establishing complete
control of the government while enacting
right-wing fascist policies with nearly
absolute power belonging to him seeing
weakness in the League of Nations Hitler
saw to mimic Benito's actions initiating
a march on Berlin during the Beer Hall
push while his actions ultimately failed
the Nazi Party had achieved a moral
victory during which Hitler spent his
time in prison writing mine Kampf which
detailed the belief of the German Weimar
Republic had been complicit in
destroying German society at the behest
of jeers as well as a plan to reinstate
Germany as a world power rallying the
desperate and impoverished German people
Hitler used the party's newfound
popularity to force the German
government's hand becoming Chancellor
and eventually dictator in asia the far
eastern crisis or a Manchurian incident
was another failure of the league under
flimsy pretext sent through
manipulations by the hand Japan invaded
the Chinese region of Manchuria and set
up a public government however with both
Japan and China being members of the
league at the time the league nearly
unanimously passed that Japan was the
aggressor and should return Manchuria to
China instead Japan withdrew from the
lead and should have faced economic
sanctions but with the league's key
members of Britain France and Russia
facing economic hardships at the time
they did neither and Japan kept
Manchuria and during this time and
within Britain itself a young student
named Herbert Wyndham had become
obsessed with the works of Nathaniel
Essex regarding the evolution of
humanity and the human genome building a
genetic accelerator and experimenting on
various rats and small animals Wyndham
swore on him to the attention of fader a
former member of the Inhumans Royal City
who was exiled for his views on cloning
providing the young man with a full map
of the human genome Wyndham went forward
developing isotope a an act which saw
him expel from Oxford University joining
forces with Jonathon drew the scientists
built a compound in the wundagore
mountains of Eastern Europe elsewhere by
1935 Italy had invaded Abyssinia now
modern-day Ethiopia at the time Africa
was divided up into several colonies
owned by various countries and with
Wakanda isolated from the rest of the
world the technologically advanced
nation took no concern with the
goings-on of its surroundings as a
result Ethiopia's emperor and his army
were poorly trained and equipped in
comparison to Italy's a large occupation
force which employed airstrikes mustard
gas and poisoning of water supplies
interestingly enough Hillier supplied
Ethiopia with rifles and machine guns
and hopes that Italy would be weakened
enough that they would not oppose Hitler
when he invaded Austria but after
recognizing the true victory would be
achieved through deception instead of
brute force Germany initiated the
formation of the Axis powers alongside
Japan and Italy where the Nazis
continued their expansion in the years
leading up to World War two within
Germany itself the world saw the arrival
of one of its most dangerous villains
born in 1914 with his mother dying in
childbirth Johann Schmidt was resigned a
Munich's home for wayward boys living a
life of destitution due to the lack of
funds from the German government
Hitler's views of returning Germany to
his former glory resonated with Johan
escaping the orphanage
for the next several years Johan
travelled through Germany continuing to
fall down the rabbit hole of the Nazis
continued rise be funding and betraying
various men and women eventually Johan
reconnected with dieter Lehman another
boy from the orphanage who was inspired
by Johan to run away while the paths of
the two boys would lead them down
separate roads with neither a line with
the Communist Russians and Schmidt
aspiring to become part of the German SS
despite his best efforts
Schmidt remained a member of the
Brownshirts constantly finding himself
the subject of abuse and discrimination
from the superior SS viewing this
treatment as an extension of Hitler's
cruelty Schmidt and dieter formed a plan
to kill the Fuhrer as a brown coat
despite being considered one of the
lowest members of the Nazi Party Schmitz
positions still granted him some measure
of information regarding the inner
workings of the Nazi Party itself
learning that Hitler intended to execute
all leader to the Browncoats during the
night of the Long Knives Schmidt and
dieter traveled to the hotel - flower
owing to the idea of Hitler intending to
kill Ernst röhm personally disguising
themselves as bellhops in arriving
moments after the Gestapo and the moment
of truth
Schmidt turned against dieter shooting
him in the head gaining an audience with
Hitler directly who was impressed by
yo.hannes actions and dedication to the
Nazi cause Schmidt was taken in by
Hitler and raised as his right-hand man
back in the United States while Nazi
Germany invaded Poland and initiated
World War two the US government looked
to counter the Nazi regime using
technology of their own turning to
Professor Phineas T Horton a pioneer in
the field of artificial intelligence and
robotics the government intended to
initiate an army of soldiers using
autonomous supercomputers programmable
for the purpose of carrying out the
goals of their commanders falling in
line with his pursuit of fame and
fortune
professor Finney has set about
developing horton cells synthetic
replicas of human cells using plastic
and carbon polymers encountering a
series of struggles after due diligence
and sleepless nights in November of 1939
professor Phineas T Horton unveiled his
creation to the world dubbed the Human
Torch never in a million years would I
have thought this when I started nobody
had any respect for Marvel and I didn't
mean for Marvel comic books in fact
that's why I changed my name my name is
to be Stanley Martin Lieber a real
normal name and I cut it in half and
made Stanley into Stan Lee I didn't even
want people to know I was working in
comics at that time because I say nobody
had any respect but they were thought to
be read by very young children or
illiterate adults today comic books are
actually written by some of the best
writers in the country if not the world
I don't have to say how good the
illustrators are or yeah they do is look
at some of the illustrations it has
become a really viable and impressive
art form and literary form
while Jim Hammond went forward as a
human torch coming to grips with
society's view of him and the Atlantic
Ocean
another super-powered being was emerging
a human Atlantean hybrid and the years
leading up to World War two the United
Kingdom's Prime Minister Winston
Churchill had sought to capture
vibranium as a material used for weapons
against the Axis powers and struck ting
English explorer Ernest Shackleton to
search the Atlantic and during their
explorations the ship was lost and
Ernest was presumed dead Antony to
capitalize on the UK's venture and
proceed of advancing their own weapons
program in the twilight of his life
US President Woodrow Wilson had
instructed Leonard McKenzie to continue
the search taking to the Atlantic and
conducting a series of explosions on the
ice Mackenzie's actions caught the
attention of Atlantean king zakkour who
instructed his daughter Finn to
investigate storing a bore of a Kenzie's
ship and being taken prisoner miss time
progressed Mackenzie and Fenn fell in
love however on the day of their
marriage the ship of McKenzie was
attacked by Atlanteans under the orders
of retrieving princess Finn and when
Leonard was believed dead Fenn returned
to her kingdom pregnant with Leonard's
child christening her son named were his
early years were spent learning about
his mixed heritage leading to a
curiosity about the surface world
however when the Nazis learned of
vibranium is existence and pursued the
rare metal for their own uses their
exploration send near discovery of
Atlantis led Namor to take up arms
against Hitler and his forces within the
United States itself the newly formed
Captain America was rising as a symbol
for the American people and the Allied
powers representing the principle of
freedom and the sacrifices that came
with it and the eyes of military
personnel Steve Rogers conviction was
his weakness believing that there were
times when torture and killing was
necessary and an effort to ensure their
plans for espionage and subterfuge were
carried out Rogers was partnered with a
teenage boy named James Buchanan Barnes
losing his mother in childbirth and his
father to a training accident Bucky was
trained as a black ops agent with
emphasis on torture and stealth fighting
alongside Captain America named war the
Submariner and Jim Hammond the Human
Torch the group named themselves the
invaders and led a series of campaigns
to thwart the Nazi regime
however the Nazis themselves were not
without their own secret weapon
continuing his tutelage under the
direction of Adolf Hitler Johann Schmidt
came to view aid off as a hindrance to
his goal of world domination
assassinating Hitler's closest advisors
and positioning himself as a second most
powerful person in Germany even Hitler
himself came to fury Johan due to his
ruthlessness and cunning believing that
world domination would require a
collaborative effort far beyond Hitler's
primitive views Johan turned his sights
to the legendary general Baron von
Strucker a signing structure to the Far
East johan's intention was to form a
pact with the Japanese mystics known as
the hand using their magic to complement
Germany's military tactics and by
combining their forces a sub sect of the
hand joined Baron von Strucker giving
birth to the second iteration of Hydra
back in Germany proper the Third Reich
had already begun a series of campaigns
aimed at eliminating the Jewish
population where this included the now
infamous final solution the desire of
Nazis to remove undesirables had
unexpected consequences most notably the
emergence of one of the earth's most
powerful mutants the son of a former
Jewish soldier turned watchmaker max
Eisen Hart's father and grandfather had
viewed their Satan life is temporary
believing that their displacement within
the Warsaw Ghetto
would give way to the return to a life
of normalcy at the war's conclusion
however whether this view was held to a
refusal to acknowledge the truth or a
genuine belief varies but this
perception was ultimately shattered when
the Nazis began transporting the
inhabitants of the Warsaw Ghetto to the
Treblinka extermination camp escaping
from their captors with the intention of
taking refuge in a safe house for German
Jews max was forced to bear witness as
his family was systematically murdered
by Nazi soldiers and thrown into a mass
grave taken to the Auschwitz
concentration camp max was assigned to
the Sonderkommando x' task was cleaning
out the cremation ovens and gas chambers
while destroying the bodies of those
exterminated by the Nazis coming to
grips with the brutality of humans
Max's experience shaped him on a
fundamental level but the truth was far
more terrifying than fiction with his
genetic manipulations by apocalypse mr.
sinister used his longevity to
experiment on humans in an effort to
understand the human genome viewing
concentration camps as the perfect
setting to conduct these experiments
without question the fledgling mutant
community within Auschwitz saw their
bodies mutilated through gruesome
experiments remaining woefully unaware
of the doctors true identity and using
his experience as a small-time smuggler
of goods within the Warsaw Ghetto max
eased as harsh resistance within ash
woods by bribing the guards with goods
unavailable through conventional means
reuniting with his childhood crush Magda
during his time in Auschwitz max
Magda and other members of the
concentration camp alongside rebels on
the outside intended to launch a
revolution freeing themselves from the
yoke of oppression coinciding with the
arrival of Captain America Bucky Namor
and Jim Hammond as they cut a swath
through the German front Max and Magda
use the Auschwitz Revolution to escape
and made their way to the Carpathian
Mountains where they began their life
together in marriage
while world war two raged on the forces
of Captain America Bucky named where the
Submariner and Jim Hammond carried out a
series of campaigns on behalf of the
Allied powers taking them to the
farthest corners of the world these acts
were in and of themselves targeted at
stopping the Nazi advancement
transitioning to northern Africa
despite his blunder and allowing the
Allied forces to invade Normandy
Erwin Rommel was still considered to be
one of Hitler's highest-ranking generals
leading a campaign to take wakanda's
vibranium stories despite his advanced
weaponry the wakandans were unable to
hold off the forces of Rommel for any
real measure of time as a result the
invaders were successful in defeating
the Nazis under Ramos command and Rogers
was rewarded with the shard of vibranium
Commission aid the intelligence branch
of the United States to develop a new
shield and during the process one of its
scientists quite literally fell asleep
waking up to a medal of indestructible
composition in the shape of a perfect
circle providing Captain America with
the shield he desired under the
direction of the US government the
scientists went forward attempting to
recreate the alloy
with a suicide of Adolf Hitler marking
the beginning of the end for the Third
Reich not all of his forces went quietly
as the top scientists under the Nazi
regime Baron Zemo stood is the 12th
generation in his family's line to carry
the name drawing the attention of the
Allied powers owing to his creation of
the Medusa effect a weapon capable of
annihilating the entirety of the United
States Army Air Forces the invaders were
tasked with bringing down Zemo and
taking him into allied custody however
after invading his fortress and
attempting to destroy a drone plane the
ensuing conflict saw both Steve Rogers
and Bucky Barnes thrown into the icy
waters of the English Channel while
Rogers would be frozen in suspended
animation for several decades Bucky
Barnes was not so lucky with the Russian
government looking to the premise of
Captain America the communist regime
intended to launch its own super soldier
program while one half of the government
targeted his fledgling even community
looking to brainwash them into
subservience the body of Bucky Barnes
was located and taken by KGB general
Alexander Lucan concluding that both
Rogers and Barnes had been killed in
action
the US government needed a response
believing that if the American people
learned of Rogers and Barnes death that
the moral compass for the last vestiges
of the war effort would crumble because
the US and Russia were running headlong
into the Cold War the US government
chose to appoint a series of successors
operating under the mantles of Captain
America and Bucky Barnes with a public
failing to know the difference in their
mind Steve Rogers remained a staunch
protector for all they held dear across
the Atlantic in upstate New York a young
Charles Xavier was coping with radical
changes of his life born to Brian and
Sharon Xavier the life of Charles was
part and parcel to government
experimentation continuing his schemes
and understanding the mutant and human
genomes mr. sinister long life allowed
for a multitude of schemes and plans
while the fall of Auschwitz led to the
abandonment of his experimentation
without question his ability to alter
his own physical appearance allowed for
integration into the scientific
community using less than savory methods
using Brian Xavier and his partner Kurt
Marko as unwitting accomplices the two
used the resources of the United States
government to analyze the genes of
mutants providing considerable
compensation for their efforts when
Brian Xavier died in an explosion Charon
inherited this wealth along with Kurt's
affections and tuning to make his way
into the marriage bed Kurt was a cruel
father to his biological son Kane
instead showing affection to Charles
however this was revealed to be a ruse
by Kurt who would used the motivation of
ensuring that he inherited all of
Sharon's wealth nevertheless Kurt's
perceived doting on Charles led to a
bitter hatred from Kane which was
compounded by the act of accidentally
killing his father and learning that
Charles Xavier possessed the power to
read minds while this would mark a
drastic change in the life of Charles
Xavier as beau he and Kane went forward
bitter enemies unbeknownst to either of
these men the earth and the rest of the
universe's inhabitants existence as they
knew it was only one part of a larger
experiment it began in the realm beyond
the multiverse home to the ivory kings
these white lords from wild space were
nothing if not curious operating with
unknown origins and unmatched power at
some point in the past the beyonders
took notice of the multiverse and the
denizens has within restricted to a
dimension devoid of time but part and
parcel to the space itself the beyonders
found a nonlinear existence to be
something of intrigue what was time what
was death and what was life what did it
mean to be both an individual and part
of a larger whole
and tending to find answers to their
questions by launching a grand
experiment the beyonders set in motion a
series of events which could not be
undone
[Music]
I'd make people not hate each other
because of their religion because of
their nationality because of any stupid
reason if we could abolish hatred we
live on this gorgeous planet there's a
character I wrote called the Silver
Surfer and I always had him making those
kind of remarks philosophical things
about he was from another world and he
said why don't we realize we're on a
planet that gives us everything food
beautiful weather
Sun everything why don't we enjoy it why
do we spend time fighting and hating
each other I love driving the Silver
Surfer
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you